So we talked about the impeachment news, the
house sending impeachment articles to the
Senate.
They've approved seven impeachment managers
who will be effectively serving as prosecutors
during the impeachment trial.
I believe with a 99% degree of confidence
that an acquittal for Donald Trump is what
is awaiting us at the end of this trial.
This has made Donald Trump short circuit.
He immediately blew a gasket and started tweeting
nonsense yesterday.
Let's look at what happened as he learned
that Democrats were indeed moving forward
and sending articles of impeachment to the
Senate, which remember, he claimed to want
initially when he was impeached in the house,
and Nancy Pelosi said, I'm going to hold the
articles until such time that I believe I
can get a fair trial.
Uh, Donald Trump said she can't do that.
She's got to move forward.
It's got to go now that it's happening.
Trump again blows a gasket and there's a lot
here because Donald Trump seemed genuinely
thrown by this.
Donald Trump tweeting, crying.
Chuck Schumer just said, the American people
want a fair trial in the Senate.
True.
But why didn't nervous Nancy and corrupt politician
Adam shifty Schiff give us a fair trial in
the house?
It was the most lopsided and unfair basement
hearing in the history of Congress.
There are so many lies and deceptions there
that it would take a long time to go through
the mall, the basement hearing thing.
Remember Republicans could be part of those,
uh, of questioning those witnesses and reviewing
those documents.
That's a lie.
The nicknaming nervous Nancy corrupt politician,
Adam shift the shifts.
I find it very funny.
I find it effective.
I obviously don't believe the smears that
are implied there.
And then again, the idea that there was no
fair trial in the house.
It's not a trial in the house.
It's a hearing.
Donald Trump was invited and he refused to
go the basis that it would not have been fair.
But then he says the fact that he didn't participate
as evidence of unfairness.
Well, if you go and it would be unfair, and
if you don't go in, it's unfair.
That's not really an honest assessment of
what went on.
Donald Trump continuing on Twitter, going
on to say, here we go again.
Another con job by the do nothing.
Democrats again do nothing.
They impeached you.
So they're doing something.
All of this work was supposed to be done by
the house, not the Senate.
Trump seemingly misunderstanding how the constitutionally
enshrined process of impeachment works.
Then in comes Donald Trump jr not the dumbest
of the Trump adult children.
Uh, but certainly not the one with the most
common sense either starting to tweet stuff,
like for example, Rand is 100%, right?
If we hear from witnesses, we should hear
from them all Hunter, Joe, BS, whistleblower,
Schiff, et cetera.
If Republicans continued the Dem one way sham,
because they're too weak to fight like Pelosi,
they don't deserve to be reelected.
And then of course, what you have to understand
is that they want to make impeachment about
Adam Schiff or the Bidens.
They want to out the whistleblower.
This is not actually about Joe and Hunter
Biden.
We knew they would try to make it about Joe
and Hunter Biden.
But what Donald Trump did is what Donald Trump
did.
And the, the, the Caroneous thick nature of
Hunter Biden, uh, being on the board of this
gas company, uh, we can all agree it's problematic
as a systemic issue, but it does not go to
the specifics of what Donald Trump did.
So distraction distortion, all of it.
Then, uh, Don jr re-tweeting some guy named
Paul Sperry who said quote Nadler Jessica
and Adler just complained.
The Senate is engaging in a disgusting coverup
by not putting on Democrats witnesses, but
the only cover up is impeachment itself.
Schiff Pelosi, Biden, and he cites a name
that is, is sometimes attributed to be one
of the whistleblowers all trying to cover
up their own roles in Ukrainian corruption,
[inaudible] election interference.
Then re-tweeting Republican Congressman Lee
Zeldin who says the most relevant to witnesses
on the obstruction of Congress charge are
Jerry Nadler and Adam Schiff.
So during this impeachment trial, there is
going to be a persistent nonstop campaign
of disinformation and distraction and character
assassination and we just have to be ready
for it.
We are looking at how much of the impeachment
trial will will be public, how much of it
can we reasonably stream on YouTube and Twitch
with commentary with the staffing resources
that we have.
Our resources were stretched basically to
the max during the impeachment hearings in
the house.
Intel and judiciary committees, sometimes
12 hour streams in a single day.
This is really important.
So we're doing what we can to plan around
how to bring as much of this to you on our
platforms as possible.
We want to be covering all of it.
That's the plan.
I'll hopefully have more information for you
about that on Monday.
The way this is expected to go is at first
there will be like three to four full days
of what the Senate would call housekeeping.
Before the trial even starts setting rules
and establishing procedures.
They would then send a summons to Trump for
a plea.
I'm sure Trump will plead not guilty.
They will then figure out which witnesses
are we going to call.
Are we sending subpoenas, scheduling witnesses?
This could be weeks in total.
The Senate has to vote on each subpoena.
It's going to be wild.
Mitch McConnell has said that the Senate will
be in session six days a week to keep things
moving.
Bill Clinton's impeachment trial lasted five
weeks.
This one could be the same.
It is going to start to overlap and conflict
with the 2020 primaries.
It is going to be an historic event and we
are going to be here for it to the extent
that we can probably more news on Monday about
the particulars.
In the meantime, again, if you see a conviction
at the end of this, let me know on Twitter
at the Pacman or in a comment down below by
leaving a comment.
I do want to hear it from